über 27 millionen menschen sind
inzwischen aus der ukraine geflohen 1,7
millionen menschen davon sind allein
nach polen gegangen und zehntausende
gehen weiter nach deutschland allein in
berlin kommen im schnitt 10.000 menschen
am tag an wie wollen wir das
organisieren wie können wir das
bewältigen
das haben wir heute die innenministerin
nancy faeser gefragt ich hoffe so eine
ganz gute frage sie haben gerade in der
in der bpk gesagt sie seien nicht
überrascht gewesen von der zahl der
flüchtlinge ihr sprecher hat gestern
gesagt mit der anzahl der menschen die
halbe kommen sind hätte man nicht
rechnen können was von beidem stimmt
also ich hab ja darauf hingewiesen eben
dass man das kriegsgeschehen ja nicht
vorher beurteilen konnte wie wirkt sich
das auf die geflüchteten aber in der
frage sind wir überrascht über die
aufnahme von geflüchteten aus
kriegsgebieten das sind wir natürlich
nicht
wir wussten nicht welche zahlen genau
kommen das hat er sicherlich damit
gemeint und dennoch erleben wir jetzt
zahlen die höher sind als in den pigs
2015 2016 glauben sie dass sie basiert
schon genug gemacht haben dass die
verteilung über die bundesländer
gelingen kann und dass das eine adäquate
unterbringung für alle wird das glaube
ich ja weil wir von anfang an mit den
bundesländern gemeinsam daran gearbeitet
haben auch gerecht und solidarisch zu
verteilen wir machen es seit gestern mit
dem königsteiner schlüssel so dass jeder
sehr klar weiß was kommt auf ihn zu und
insofern ist das glaube ich etwas was
sehr gut gelingt gerade in der
zusammenarbeit und ich bin den
bundesländern den kommunen sehr sehr
dankbar dass sie das so toll stimmen
letzte frage warum weigern sie sich noch
immer die menschen direkt an den grenzen
zu überlassen erfassen also stationären
grenzkontrollen einzurichten weil
tatsächlich besitzen ja nicht nur
menschen in zügen es gibt mehrere wege
hierher zu kommen das wissen sie besser
als ich warum er fasst man die nicht
sowie 20 25 16 an stationären
grenzkontrollen also zum einen noch mal
es gibt eine völlig andere situation als
2015 mit einem kriegsgeschehen mitten in
europa zu tun das was völlig anderes als
2015 im moment haben sie überhaupt keine
rechtlichen grundlagen
diese grenzkontrollen so wie sie es
gerade beschrieben haben durchzuführen
deshalb unterscheidet sich das von 2015
elementar
wir haben gemeinschaftliches
europäisches vorgehen und dazu haben wir
uns mit einer richtlinie so vereinbart
wie wir es jetzt machen
[Musik]
unter den geflüchteten ist es offenbar
zu einem schrecklichen fall von
sexuellem missbrauch gekommen eine
18-jährige ukraine wurde vergewaltigt
auf diesem hotel schiff wurde sie von
den behörden auf dem rhein
einquartiert sie glaubte sich in
sicherheit doch riina wurde opfer
sexueller übergriffe nacheinander von
zwei männern aus dem irak und nigeria
auch sie kam aus der ukraine sollen die
doppelte staatsbürgerschaft gehabt haben
wie sie genau an den ukrainischen pass
gekommen sind ist jetzt teil
polizeilicher ermittlungen und wir gehen
zu frank schneider unsere
nordrhein-westfalen chefreporter franke
was weißt du über die hintergründe aber
wir gehen auch zu ankara steht dort war
an der grenze zu polen späte machen wir
es nacheinander frank was weißt du über
die hintergründe was sind die aktuellen
informationen
mittlerweile sind schlimme details
bekannt die junge frau nachdem sie von
den beiden männern attackiert worden ist
und in ihrem zimmer angegriffen und
missbraucht worden ist hat sich dann
ihrem zimmer eingeschlossen hat von dort
eine bekannte angerufen die auch hier in
düsseldorf ist und die wohl woanders
untergekommen war und die hat dann die
polizei angerufen und das zeigt so ein
bisschen was auch die befürchtungen der
behörden ist es gibt vielleicht eine
viel höhere dunkelziffer von frauen die
sich nicht trauen die angst haben wenn
sie sich an die behörden wenn hat das
möglicherweise auswirkungen auf ihren
flüchtlingsstatus oder wie auch immer
und deswegen appelliert die polizei
nochmal wer etwas mitbekommt wer wem
selber etwas passiert wenn mitarbeiter
etwas mitbekommen von
hilfsorganisationen bitte sofort die
polizei zu informieren damit man etwas
machen kann wir können hier einmal
runterschauen hier unten liegt das
schiff ich war eben mal dort unten vor
ort und wollte gerne mit den
verantwortlichen und den betreiber
sprechen das aber kein interesse da muss
man vorsichtig zu formulieren
man sagte mir wir sollen das doch nicht
so aufbauschen sei doch nur ein fall auf
dem schiff und außerdem seien die frauen
jetzt runter vom schiff design jetzt
woanders untergebracht und damit könnte
ja auch wohl nichts mehr passieren es
steht ein sicherheitsbeamter vor der tür
und damit ist das problem hier offenbar
erledigt man muss ja auch sehen die
polizei hat es nicht bekanntgegeben die
polizei hat gesagt na ja wir hatten ja
die täter warum sollen wir endlichkeit
informieren es hängt wieder genauso an
wie wir schon mal erlebt haben probleme
wirklich schlimme probleme werden
einfach negiert und wenn ich gerade die
bundesinnenministerium höhere die ja
auch so tut als sei das alles wunderbar
im griff ich kann nur sagen dann sollte
sie mal mit ihren beamten sprechen sie
ist ja nun auch schon ein paar wochen im
amt und dann soll sie mal ihre
bundespolizisten fragen da habe ich
heute mich fast ganz anderes gehört wir
erzählen an den grenzen von dramatischen
bildern von nicht mehr nur jungen frauen
mit kindern gekommen denn das war der
unterschied zur flüchtlingswelle 2015 es
kam frauen mit kindern weil die männer
in der ukraine bleiben dort kämpfen
müssen sogar die dürfen gar nicht das
land verlassen und jetzt kommen große
gruppen von jungen männern alle wie
sagte der bundespolizist so schön zu mir
und nicht vom kaukasischen phänotyp
sondern aus arabischen ländern und aus
nordafrika insbesondere und diese männer
die drängen jetzt hier nach deutschland
und haben plötzlich alle ukrainische
presse sie sind tunesier marokkaner
iraker was weiß ich und haben aber
gleichzeitig alle plötzlich einen
ukrainischen pass woher sie den haben
weiß keiner und werden gerade gehört die
bundesinnenministerium meint da muss man
auch nicht kontrollieren ist ja eine
ganz andere situation nein es mischen
sich erneut wieder menschen unter diesen
flüchtlingsstrom die möglicherweise
massive probleme hier verursachen eben
auch für die menschen die wirklich
flüchten die wirklich vor dem krieg
flüchten wie diese junge frau hier und
ich habe gerade noch mal auch schlimme
details erfahren von einer weiteren tat
am 12 märz also erst vor wenigen tagen
ist ein junger mann auch ein flüchtling
aus der ukraine in der messehalle hier
in düsseldorf vergewaltigt worden man
hat auch verletzungen im genitalbereich
festgestellt und dort sind wiederum zwei
männer unter verdacht geraten auch die
haben einen ukrainischen pass waren
deshalb in der gleichen unterkunft aber
komischerweise auch einen marokkanischen
pass und der mann hat ausgesagt man hat
ihm etwas zu trinken gegeben dann kann
er sich an nichts mehr erinnern oder
nächsten morgen ist ein massivsten
verletzungen und schmerzen in seinem
zimmer wach geworden also wenn die
bundes innenministerin einfach mal hört
was da gerade passiert was ihre
polizisten sagen können dann sollte sich
vielleicht mal dringend überlegen ob man
da nicht ganz schnell gegensteuern muss
man schneider in düsseldorf danke
dorthin und dann schauen wir doch mal
wie es auf polnischer seite gehandhabt
wird der prix courage ist für uns sehen
media an der polnisch ukrainischen
grenze läuft es da anders als an der
deutsch polnischen grenze
ja also hier an dieser grenze bzw an der
polnischen grenze zur ukraine dieser
insgesamt 530 kilometer lang
da haben wir stehen wir jetzt zum
beispiel gerade im medica eigentlich an
dem größten grenzübergang und dort wird
so kontrolliert dass man praktisch als
ukraine kurz seinen pass vorzeigen muss
das gepäck wird nur sporadisch control
kontrolliert weil der andrang einfach so
groß ist vor rund drei wochen vier
wochen hat man noch gesagt dass die
polnischen r grenzen eigentlich in der
lage während bis zu 50.000 menschen am
tag aufzunehmen jetzt sind es
mittlerweile bis zu 100000 am tag und
insgesamt sind hier auch schon 1,6
millionen menschen angekommen wir können
ein bisschen in die richtung schwenken
man geht er über einen kleineren
steinweg
gehen die menschen praktisch ein
kilometer lang von der ukrainischen
grenzkontrolle bis hierher über das
heißt sie haben manchmal schon drei tage
fußweg hinter sich und gehen dann drei
tage fußweg entschuldigungen drei tage
reise hinter sich und nimmt man
praktisch ein kilometer fußweg auf sich
teils teilweise wirklich sehr schwer
bepackt einige menschen kommen auf
krücken andere im rollstuhl andere mit
drei kleinen kindern oder mit
neugeborenen auf den arm und man muss
hier wirklich sagen die polnische
hilfsbereitschaft ist hier schon sehr
sehr groß dass es kam meistens sofort
polnische soldaten hier eben zu diesem
grünen zaun und nehmen dann neugeborene
entgegen nehmen sie den müttern ab so
dass die mitte ihm keine so große last
mehr zu tragen haben annika wie läuft es
mit der registrierung ab wir haben
gehört aus dem innenministerium in
deutschland da soll eine vereinfachte
registrierung zum tragen kommen und
chaos und lange wartezeiten zu
verhindern menschen müssen sich
überhaupt nur registrieren wenn sie
leistungen begehrten wie läuft die
registrierung dort ab
wie gesagt es muss eigentlich nur ein
pass vorgezeigt werden das gepäck wird
nur sporadisch kontrolliert wir waren
vorhinein cher michelle das ungefähr
zehn kilometer von hier entfernt da gibt
sozusagen ein erstaufnahmelager für
flüchtlinge in denen sich dann praktisch
mitfahrgelegenheiten also fahrer die
sich aus deutschland oder irgendwo aus
europa anbieten ukraine mit nach hause
zu nehmen müssen sich dort registrieren
müssen dort ihre niere passnummer
vorliegen ihr kennzeichen vorlegen und
dürfen dann erst menschen aus der
ukraine mit nach deutschland nehmen ich
würde euch aber gerne trotzdem gern
einmal hier zeigen wie das hier einmal
aussieht weil das ist wirklich eine
riesige hilfsbereitschaft die man hier
in polen erlebt in den letzten tagen
also hier auf der rechten seite sehen
wir zum beispiel baby also zum beispiel
windeln
teilweise auch babynahrung an den
ständen und
hier sehen wir links und rechts auch die
menschen sitzen die sich natürlich auch
nach ihrer reise auch teilweise erst mal
ausruhen müssen erst mal hinsetzen
müssen weil sie oft auch wirklich weite
strecken gehen mussten wie gesagt schwer
bepackt hier sehen wir zum beispiel
einen einkaufswagen der dann von einem
freiwilligen geschoben wird mit dem
gepäck damit die menschen eben nicht all
ihre taschen selbst tragen müssen und
hier auf der rechten seite sehen wir
kleidungsstücke die eben auch gespendet
werden weil viele natürlich auch nur das
wenigste
einpacken konnten für ihre kinder für
sich selbst und sich dann praktisch neu
ausstatten müssen hier gibt es
verpflegung und so geht es eben jetzt
auch paar hundert meter noch so weiter
und am ende dieses weges halten die
busse die dann die menschen entweder
nach deutschland bringen oder zum
flughafen oder eben zu den orten wo sie
sich zumindest erstmal ausruhen und
schlafen können ankara stiegen dank und
wir schauen noch mal nach deutschland
frank schneider wie geht die
bundespolizei vor
naja die bundespolizei sagte jetzt ganz
klar in der grenze ist folgendes problem
die doppelstaatsbürgerschaft die ja die
herrschaften vorweisen wo man nicht weiß
genau woher haben sie
entschuldigung sie zeigen bei der
ausreise man sagen sie einen
marokkanischen pass oder tunesischen
pass oder algerischen pass oder
irakischen passt weil sonst dürften sich
die ukraine gar nicht verlassen sie sind
ja im wehrpflichtigen alter und wenn sie
dann ein stück weiter an der polnischen
grenze sind zeigen sie dort den
ukrainischen pass und wir haben ja
gerade von annika graf gehört und hat
gar nicht kontrolliert sein ukrainischen
pass hat der wird durchgewunken und
genau das ist der trick deshalb die
beiden pässe und wir hören hier von der
bundespolizei das ist gerade in der
ukraine einen immensen schwarzmarkt
geben soll wo man günstig für ein paar
euro an pässe führerschein und ähnliche
papiere kommen soll und teilweise gibt
es wohl auch fälle wo leute natürlich
sagen ja ich bin geflüchtet ich konnte
nichts mit nämlich etwas zurück gelassen
was in teilen sicherlich auch stimmen
wird aber eben bei bestimmten personen
noch nicht stimmt aber es wird einfach
durchgewunken und die polin sagen wollen
ihren verbindungsbeamten grund ist das
mehr oder weniger egal weil die personen
also viele flüchtlinge bleiben in polen
das sind aber die ukraine aber diese
anderen flüchtlinge die sich als ukraine
ausgeben ist aber gar nicht sind die
wollen gar nicht bei uns bleiben den
reichen die sozialleistungen bei uns gar
nicht die wollen weiter nach deutschland
deswegen wenn wir die einreisen lassen
die sind sowieso nach zwei tagen wieder
weg wie gesagt ich kann nur hoffen dass
im bundesinnenministerium diese
problematik schnell erkannt wird und wir
nicht auf probleme zu steuern die wir
jetzt alle überhaupt nicht gebrauchen
können frank schneider danke und danke
annika